[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
kangourou
kangourous mon gentil petit kangourou
aux yeux verts au poil rou on t'aimait
ici beaucoup on t'avait rapporté du pays
des grands étés d'Australie dans un lit
un petit lit de paille bien joli
kangourou kangourou les premiers jours
furent si doux tu sautais comme un fou
gangadant un peu partout sous les arbres
dans leurs fleurs tu faisais joli cœur
les voisins sans courou disait qu'il est
gentil ce
grandourou tu grandis tu grandis le
jardin devint trop petit à la fin
rassasier de jouer àassute rosier saute
Lila saute gazon un beau jour tu fis un
bon et franchis c'est malin le mur de la
maison rue
saintpulin un gendarme qui passait scria
mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ce gros
lapin de chou qui saute le mur de chez
vous je lui dis ce lapin chez le
gendarme c'est c'est un copain sans
m'entendre il Tène pour t'en fermer aux
EAU DE
Vincen nous venions le jeudi tapporter
des fruits confit tristement tu
regardais les Badeau qui te badai et ton
œil semblait dire est-ce bien vrai ou
est-ce pour rire ou pour faire une
chanson que tu m'as fait jeter dans
cette prison vint l'automne des jours
froids et je compris ce jour ma foi en
venant un jeudi que tu allais mourir
d'ennui jus alors du chagrin de t'avoir
ramené de si loin sans savoir que ton
bonheur c'était de vivre au pays de ton
cœur kangourou kangourou tu partis
gentil comme tout pour des lieux
merveilleux où l'on voir passer le bon
Dieu mais parfois quand le soleil brise
de c'estes rayons vermeill la pluie fine
du mois d'oût je crois te voir làhaut
mon
congourou librement librement tu
comambates au fir man sur de beau nuages
perchés tu t'amuses à sautecher saute
toi de la maison saute les vers de ma
chanson Pointin les cage des verrou et
sans rcune pour moi mon
kangour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]